I'm stealing a Hollywood Reporter
question here but what would you say to
a 22 year old Zach Perez in 2012 what
would I tell them so you get ready
because you're gonna get your ass kicked
all up and down the street for about 20
years so you better you know you better
be ready to get beat up you know because
I mean that's nothing new I mean that
everybody does I told myself what I was
gonna go through I wonder I don't know I
don't know if I I don't think I wouldn't
have would not have done it but it's
like all right I just think it's a you
know it's a tough business
and-and-and and it helps you in the
beginning to be ignorant because that
naivety protects you that sort of like
hopefulness protects you and it actually
enables you to create stuff which is
great but you also have to be ready for
the reality of the business which is
that you know there's a lot of people
out there all trying to do the same
thing and you know even if you're
talented that doesn't mean that you're
gonna be rewarded and you have to find a
way to I would say to a young filmmaker
that it's important to define in your
mind going into it what success means
that's the thing that I think I missed
messed up i associated success with you
know whether I was gonna get hired again
by whether if I made an independent
movie and then a studio hired me to make
the movie that means that I'm successful
that means I'm approved or that if my
movie got picked up by a distributor or
got picked up by Sundance or a fast off
a festival that is success because that
means that I've been like knighted or
stamped that's like the biggest mistake
anybody can make because success that's
subjective I mean who are these people
at Sundance that are deciding what gets
in who are these people I mean they're
not like these mystical magical people
there's people and they have their own
agendas and that doesn't mean that
you're not as good as that all it means
is that they decided to pick somebody
else for whatever reason and the same
thing goes with distribution you can
have your movie done and you
it could be great and somebody
distributes some piece of crap thing
because they think that's gonna make
more money that has nothing to do with
the quality of your work and I made
certain III it certainly had times where
I was like you know down on myself
because I didn't tick these boxes that I
had had set for myself and it's
perfectly fine to set you know to be
ambitious and I've never stopped being
ambitious but don't I feel it's
important not to judge yourself based on
things that you can't control I think
it's more important to ask that when
you're taking criticism from somebody
it's more important to know like who am
i listening to you know like I would
much rather take criticism from someone
I respect than just someone like
test-market of schmoes that des i you
know that's that's where you can kind of
go off the rails so don't be so hard on
yourself I guess is the is the thing I
would say
you